brace you from any other girl
that would validate him actually giving
you that lifestyle why would he give you
that
versus giving somebody else that or I
make a sandwich
it's a lot of girls that make sandwiches
and give phenomena
I mean the sandwiches
[Laughter]
but I mean for real like what what would
why would he choose you my Kick-Ass
personality and your personality and
loyalty
[Laughter]
answer should be to that
um what should what should women bring
to the table
I'ma just be honest honestly I mean I
was with the sandwich in the blood
for me um I think that if a guy reaches
a certain status in life
and he's not young right let's just say
he's above the age of 33 34 years old
right
um I don't see why he would choose
any woman to marry
once he reaches a certain threshold
interesting I don't see why he would
choose any of them you think he should
want the connection I think men want he
can have a commit connection with as
many women as he wants but that a deep
connection and intimacy and like real
like so stress you can't get that with
anyone you're not going to get that why
can't you she's gonna suck your dick and
then leave and then be not you know what
I mean you're not having that
communication you're not building
something men want I don't really think
you understand men no I think she's the
right thing no the majority of men
listen I've taught the majority of them
in my whole Adult Career I coach him
every day lead I I disagree you know do
you coach like the the guys who are
really trying to get it or do you coach
the average man how much I think that is
how much of your coaching sessions
they're a lot they're a lot are they
over a thousand I don't wanna I don't
want to say it online okay if there's a
lot then that by definition means that
you're not coaching the average man
because the average man can't afford it
so don't tell me you coach the average
man because it's not true but a mentor
yada a lot of guys and I do look at the
coaching the coaching is different than
the mentor right don't in fact coach
that no no no but see here's the here's
the caveat though lead because the
coaching session I don't know I'm gonna
add the contact you coach I'm gonna add
the contacts I'm gonna add the contact
if you don't no no no I have a certain
amount of slots
that I a lot for regular people
yeah pretty much right but and those are
the regular guys so the coaching
sessions is completely different from
the guys that you allocate a specific
amount of your time to be able to hear
from regular people because I don't want
to become so disconnected it's true but
the charity cases are a small percentage
because you don't have a lot of time
that's true but I do I do talk to a lot
of guys though you talk to some regular
dudes right I get it I get it but what
I'm saying is what she's saying is is is
is the fact most guys really want a
connection with a woman it's true but
that's not what we talking about she's
specifically no she the question was
when you reach a certain threshold the
type of guys that they want they want
the top one percent
you speaking about regular guys
they're saying I want guys that make 150
000 or more
a guy that's 20 years old on average is
not making 150 000 a year
when you start to get to a certain
threshold because most guys just making
a type of money are well into their
careers or they're they're starting to
get into that that ascending into 33 34
maybe 40 years old when those type of
guys make that type of money if they're
not already married why would they
choose them
I think the question is like why would
we care about being chosen by those
people who don't want a connection if
you're already having the mindset of
like men don't want that if I'm talking
to a man he's like hey I don't want
connection this is X Y and Z and I want
a wife in this way and he's not in a
position to give me what I want
emotionally that I can also pour into
him and help build him as a man that
he's not even a consideration I don't
care because first you can't build a man
that's a you can't build a man that's
already established as making that type
of money he's already him I think
there's a lot of men who are in
relationships new marriage as a result
of being married hear me out no you
can't build a man that's already
established he's already dedicated
growth no growth as a person
listen when you get to 70 you you don't
want the regular guy
y'all don't want regular dudes that's
what y'all said yeah that's what I'm
going off of they don't want under
121.50 for whatever reason whether it
was childhood trauma or whatever like
that they don't want that guy right so
they're not trying to build with a dude
that makes 50 60 70 000 a year on
average so when you take that into
consideration now you have to change the
terms you got to change the dynamic of
what that relationship is going to look
like because you're not talking about
building with a dude you're talking
about you talking about getting with a
dude that's already established so why
would that dude choose them that's that
God is pick of the litter
he can he his time is is is slammed most
of those types of billions
that means but like what if you're what
if I could what if we could be his peace
what if we can like you know what I mean
there's there's a lot of
there's a lot of factors that play into
it both of us did say we would build
with a man if he was willing to build
not willing to stay stagnant I don't
want an average man that's stagnant I I
don't mind being with a man making less
money if he's building and I absolutely
think that there's you know healing and
life experience that I have that I could
teach him in like are we saying that you
don't mind building with a man who's
making 150 or you don't mind building
with a man who's making 50. I don't mind
building with a man who's making under
150 if he's willing to work and make
sure I know that's a big gap 50 and
I dated again who was making 50.
building with the guy that makes 50. I
dated a man that had zero that was
making nothing a year so yes I would be
okay dating a guy making 50. okay so
then where did this whole 120 and 150 I
think we asked for a hypothetical of
like what what oh yeah
what was the floor so now we're going
yeah if I get to choose but also like if
I have a good connection with someone I
meet somebody and we're vibing we have a
good connection they have good morals
and values and we're aligned on that
then that's gonna do it at Target with
the red shirt do they make 50k yeah
is he's a manager at Target right he's
all he's overseeing uh the Home Goods
section you rocking the 30 off
let's go baby you rolling with him we
about to home decor the [__] out of this
yeah right you're rolling with him right
I'm rolling with him I don't think I
know I wouldn't date a man who works at
Target because I that's like where
you're at if you're a salesperson you're
making 50k and in two years you could
build a clientele business you could be
making more like again there's goals
absolutely I would date you at 50k yeah
but I just think like I think he's
asking like what's the minimum for I
mean we could say at a different age
it's okay as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible